à une autre info du jour vous savez
cette semaine Bruno Guillon l'animateur
de France 2 et Fun Radio a été cambriolé
menacé avec une arme séquestrée et sa
femme a été ligotée bâillonnée devant
leur enfant devant leur enfant des en
pleine nuit dans leur maison située dans
les Yvelines on pense à eux encore et on
espère qu'ils vont pas arriver à passer
un weekend correct parce que c'est vrai
que ça va être compliqué pour eux alors
si on retourne la matinale de Fun Radio
il a réussi à revenir sur ce triste
épisode avec humour sur RTL ce matin
regardez
on sort de son corps c'est c'est une
sidération
je vois ma femme
avec un pistolet sur la tempe
je suis désolé
je vois mon fils qui est menacé par par
doga
tout de suite on m'attache les mains
dans le dos on m'emmène dans la chambre
de mon fils
on dit que si jamais on fait quoi que ce
soit ils vont nous tuer
je vois ma femme avec quelqu'un d'autre
avec une arme sur la tempe et il
l'emmène dans le couloir alors je leur
demande de me prendre moi et laisser ma
femme avec mon fils
c'est extrêmement émouvant alors
effectivement le premier jour il avait
fait front et puis après il y a une
sorte de descente psychologique on
réalise et on s'effondre donc c'est des
phénomènes classiques il faut le
formaliser souvenons-nous de la violence
vous savez quand les époux tapis avaient
été aussi victime de ça mais c'était
d'une violence inouïe et il faut dire
les mots Bruno Guillon et sa famille ils
ont cru mourir parce que vous pensez que
on va vous tirer dessus qu'on va vous
frapper au marteau il y avait un marteau
donc voilà ce qu'il faut souhaiter c'est
que les enquêteurs arrêtent les
coupables est-ce que vous vous êtes déjà
arrivé on va dire papa aussi grave mais
quelque chose comme ça qui vous a
traumatisé voilà Valérie moi ça m'a
traumatisé à l'épo sur le sur le faut
alors c'est évidemment
1000 fois incomparable avec ce qu'avait
que Bruno Guillon mais c'est vrai que
lorsque j'étais à TF1 je sortais d'un
studio à La Plaine Saint-Denis
il était pas si tard que ça et j'étais
dans ma dans ma voiture alors j'imagine
qu'effectivement on avait suivi et que
le fait que je sortais des studios
j'étais dans ma voiture et en fait de
scooter quand on sort des studios il y a
un premier feu rouge puis un second et
en fait au premier feu j'ai vu de ce que
j'ai vu j'ai pas vu en fait et il y
avait deux scooters qui ont vérifié que
c'était moi j'imagine parce que c'est ce
que mon disant qui était après et au
second feu en fait de chaque côté ils
avaient des ce qu'on appelle des sortes
de baramines et en fait ils ont cassé
les quatre vitres de la voiture en même
temps donc ça fait une déflagration on a
l'impression qu'il y a un attentat qui a
quelque chose qui est voilà donc j'avais
du vert partout sur moi évidemment je
n'ai rien eu si ce n'est cette
sidération dont on parle ça vous a
traumatisé combien de temps après parce
que après en fait ils ont ensuite pris
tout ce qu'il y avait dans la voiture
mais ça dure 10 secondes qui vous semble
une éternité qui sont partis en scooter
et ils m'ont laissé là ce qui va
traumatiser c'est que les gens m'ont
doublé
oui les gens sonnent les intervenues et
ont laissé m'ont laissé dans la voiture
il savait pas forcément qui j'étais mais
voilà ils ont vu une femme seule dans
une voiture avec des voitures des vertes
péter de partout
donc moi ça ça m'a traumatisé
paradoxalement c'est le fait qu'on et
puis après cette saison des choses
toutes bêtes mais ils m'ont pris des
choses il y avait pas grand chose de
valeur dans mon sac mais je venais je
venais d'avoir mon fils qui avait
quelques mois et il y avait encore le
petit album vous savez de l'hôpital avec
les petites photos les phonétiques
photos c'est juste ce détail là et je
n'arrêtais pas de dire en boucle en
pleurant ils ont la photo de ils ont le
carnet de photos de Tom ils ont enfin de
mon fils ils ont le carnet de photos de
c'était ce petit truc là qui vont après
qui est très bête mais voilà donc ça n'a
rien à voir évidemment avec ce qui a
subi Bruno hein mais c'est c'est
évidemment un moment pas très agréable
parce que oui oui moi très jeune je
devais avoir 19 20 ans je vers chez moi
je passe sur un pont mais très très
isolé et en fait il y a il y avait un
jeune homme qui était accoudé au pont je
passe et là il arrive et j'étais l'été
j'étais décolleté j'étais vraiment très
jeune et il met ses mains là en
commençant assez un petit peu en disant
on va aller plus loin et que ça et je ne
sais pas c'est je rentre encore quand
j'y repense et je ne sais pas on a une
force incroyable je me suis entendu dire
je vais revenir il faut que j'aille la
poste et j'ai senti ces mains qui se
dénouaient et je suis parti mais
vraiment en marchant normalement sans
courir complètement tremblante mais en
disant je crois pas enfin c'est un
mauvais rêve j'ai été là où j'avais et
je suis revenu évidemment pas par le
même chemin et j'ai vu qu'il était en
train d'attendre sur le donc vous voyez
j'ai encore des des voilà j'ai encore
les poils qui se passe quand j'y pense
quoi quand j'avais pensé il y a beaucoup
de gens à qui c'est arrivé
malheureusement moi je me suis déjà fait
racketter quand j'avais 14 ans par 6
racailles qui me suivait j'étais avec ma
demi-sœur on était dans la rue autour du
lycée et il y a une bande de 6 mecs qui
sont arrivés qui se sont jetés sur moi
pour me voler ce que j'avais j'avais que
des pièces sur moi j'avais rien du tout
mais ils m'ont quand même défoncé c'est
à dire qu'ils m'ont mis au sol ils m'ont
mis des chassés et je pensais qu'il y a
une chose c'était ma sœur qui était
contre le mur terrorisé qui a 2 ans de
moins que moi et je me suis dit j'espère
qu'ils vont rien lui faire elle ne
pouvait rien faire et j'ai quand même
essayé de me battre parce que voilà je
me suis dit
et du courage mais avec six personnes
c'est c'est impossible c'est c'est
j'étais donc je suis resté au sol et
puis j'avais un sandwich à la main et je
leur ai acheté le sandwich dans la
gueule ils sont revenus pour me [__]
une deuxième une deuxième raclée voilà
c'est
ça ouais moi aussi j'avais 19 ans je
crois on est allé manger au resto avec
mes deux copines et en sortant on veut
prendre le tram donc c'est vraiment
c'était une un endroit effectivement qui
craignait un peu mais on se dit on va
aller rapidement et il y a un mec qui
est venu me parler je sais pas me
demander l'heure ou quelque chose comme
ça et donc j'étais avenant j'ai répondu
et au bout d'un moment je sais pas il y
a ces cinq autres potes qui sont venus
mais copines sont un peu parti enfin
dans le tram parce que voilà ça commence
à faire voilà et en fait ils m'ont
plaqué contre le truc du tram et voilà
il y a eu un peu des mains des trucs et
je me souviens que mes copines elles
étaient ahurie là-bas elle pouvait rien
faire et que tous les gens du tram enfin
il y a personne qui a bougé en train de
faire rien personne ne fait rien quoi
dans le métro j'ai réussi à me défiler
comme je pouvais et tout mais je veux
dire c'est impressionnant quand tu as
six mecs comme ça devant toi qui te
presse comme ça
les autres mais c'est toujours compliqué
aussi
qui a voulu lui au contraire il y a eu
une agression voilà de
s'interposer ceux qui agressé un autre
mec il a voulu s'interposer il a pris un
coup de couteau
non mais c'est pour ça qu'il faut pas
leur dire de forcément c'est vrai que
il faut non mais en revanche appeler la
police elle se met à l'écart loin et
appeler la police quand on a vu par
exemple le comportement du jeune homme
exactement un sac à dos qui est
incroyable mais c'est vrai que lui il a
eu un courage mais c'est vrai que après
on s'est compliqué de d'en vouloir
Pascal courage nécessaire mais il y a
aussi la sidération c'est à dire qu'on
comprend pas ce qui se passe et le temps
qu'on réagisse c'est trop tard
sans forcément intervenir pour retaper
les gens dans le cas d'une agression
d'une femme dans le métro enfin moi ça
m'arrivait plein de fois de me faire
agresser dans le métro et je sais à quel
point le fait qu'il y ait une autre
personne qui viennent à côté qui dit
comment ça va et tout on se connaît sans
forcément interagir dans la violence
juste être à côté et dire ça va ça fait
longtemps en fait quand on voit une
situation dans ça comme ça là de pouvoir
juste intervenir et montrer qu'on est là
pour l'autre bah c'est peut-être en
détail mais ça peut sauver quand même
des gens que le nombre fait la force
aussi c'est que quand on est dans le
métro on peut observer autour de nous
voir d'autres personnes qui peuvent
ensemble on est plus fort donc on peut
aller par rapport à ce que dit Moon ça
m'est arrivé cet été moi à la gare de la
Part-Dieu une gare de Lyon j'étais avec
elle était 4h30 du matin et elle ouvre
vers 5h30 donc on va on devait prendre
un train on était tombé en panne j'étais
avec ma fille et la fille de Fatou on
était trois donc deux jeunes filles il y
avait une jeune femme de d'à peu près 20
ans qui a été gravement importuné par un
par un homme et vraiment j'ai eu peur
qu'il agresse il est venu une fois il
est venu deux fois il a insulté lui a
mal parlé et à un moment je lui ai dit
ça n'a rien d'extrêmement courageux mais
je lui ai dit venez je vais faire comme
si vous êtes avec nous et que j'ai trois
filles avec moi je vais vous accompagner
elle est venue on a bu un café je l'ai
emmené au train et après elle m'a dit
bah comme ça ça me rassure parce que je
sais que voilà donc je corroborse que
vous dites juste un petit geste qui peut
faire que la personne se sente moins
seule et moins potentiellement agressée
[Applaudissements]